bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag un ski
mag un peu particulier du fait de la
crise sanitaire liée aux provident 19
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vit à l'heure
du conte finaux alors quelles sont les
mesures qui ont été mises en place pour
les populations pour les entreprises et
dans les transports ont fait le point
c'est parti
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines à l'heure du
coc vide 19
et du confinement
en règle générale c'est passé respecté
on a eut évoqué même à un moment donné
vous savez il ya eu une espèce de
discussions et polémiques sur les couvre
feux et pour avoir changé avec la
préfecture mais également la police
nationale et la police municipale
on s'est rendu compte que ça n'avait pas
raison d'être puisque le respect était
véritablement le présent et surtout le
ski et la nuit
[Musique]
on a des obligations à certains moments
bien sûr d'être présent j'essaye de me
déplacer de mud est confiné le moins
possible et de respecter ce qui est de
vendée aujourd'hui on a des outils vous
voyez qui sont des outils qui nous
permettent de travailler ça me permet de
travailler avec saint quentin en
yvelines
au niveau du conseil communautaire ça me
permet de travailler avec le département
également en tant que président et bien
sûr avec la ville on est en permanence
soit au téléphone soit par
visioconférence en travail complet
[Musique]
on se réunit tous les mardis matin
justement par visioconférence puisque ça
nous semble indispensable d'être
ensemble
ne serait ce que pour avoir une
cohérence de fonctionnement sur
l'agglomération
on a beaucoup travaillé aussi sur tous
ces masques comme vous le savez on est
livré par la région ile-de-france pour
lui masque on en a eu pour les médecins
on en a eu pour les soignants dans a
distribué des milliers hier c'était pour
les pharmaciens et il est clair que on
essaye de groupe et aussi nos demandes
avec les maires de l'agglomération de
façon à ce que ces biens ont soit plus
efficace et plus réactif par rapport à
nos concitoyens
[Musique]
nico des commerces l'application est
stricto sensu exactement ce que nous
demande l'état donc aujourd'hui on a on
a nos commerces de proximité qui sont
ouverts laissant entre effectivement de
premières nécessités alimentaires qui
sont également ouverts avec ce que nous
essayons de voir aussi avec hull au
respect bien sûr des gestes de barrières
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que les
gens pâtissent à ce niveau là on est
dans des accompagnements au niveau du
portage de course de portage à domicile
nous on a des chiffres vraiment en
augmentation hallucinant et c'est très
bien et on a trouvé des bénévoles pour
ça
l'agglomération a mis en place une carte
interactive recensant les commerces de
proximité qui restent ouverts achats
locaux et livraison à domicile
commerçants et saint quentinois peuvent
rejoindre le groupe facebook dédié le
dispositif national de bons d'achat
permet aussi de soutenir les commerces
non alimentaires sur notre commune et
sur saint quentin ou cissé s'est
organisé puisque dès que le marché s'est
fermé la coupe pas les commerçants du
marché ont tout de suite proposé aussi
davantage de faire des livraisons est de
pouvoir apporter ses produits frais
auprès de la population et je sais qu'il
ya eu énormément de solidarité qui sont
mis en place et des producteurs qui se
sont regroupés autour d'organisations
je crois que ça va permettre aussi aux
personnes de découvrir que nous avons
des producteurs locaux qui lie à toute
une organisation sur 50 ans avec une
richesse incroyable au niveau de ses
productions d'art
[Musique]
alors dès le début de cette de cette
crise sanitaire les services de
l'agglomération du développement
économique en était aux côtés des
entreprises d'abord mettre en place
immédiatement un accompagnement et un
guichet unique
vient ensuite les initiatives prises par
l'agglomération dans skins davantage de
son ressort nous avons par exemple juge
pendules les loyers technique
l'entreprise provoc je préside
ils sont aujourd'hui totalement suspendu
ses versements il ya aussi la même chose
au sein de l'incubateur le ski club dans
lequel il n'y a plus aucun loyer qui est
versé à l'autre bête pour l'installer
dans cette structure qui dépend de
l'agglomération et puis il en va de même
pour les remboursements de traits de
notre au fonds de prêts d'honneur et une
7050 1 dans lequel nous avons aussi
suspendu tous les remboursements encore
une fois qu'une idée simple faire le
maximum pour permettre aux entreprises
de passer des moments difficiles avec le
moins de casse possible et donc d'abord
aux angles possibles soulager leurs
trésoreries gens semblent à peu près 150
160 mille salariés en chômage partiel en
ligne à ligne c'est deux fois plus que
la moyenne nationale s'explique aussi
par le fait que notre département est
d'apprendre département très peuplées
puis un département très dynamique sur
le plan économique avec beaucoup
d'entreprises je rappelle aussi qu enfin
il ya 50 ans et demi beaucoup de cadres
qui le sont au télétravail mais grande
copine aussi dans l'autre qui chutent
saint quentin en yvelines dont on est
très fier à son très mobilisés dans les
7 9 ans et prix je pense des entreprises
comme rebours que nous valons l'humour
par exemple sont engagés sur la
fabrication des respirateurs dispositif
d'état aujourd'hui remettre quentin des
respirateurs artificiels sur leur chaîne
de production auxquelles on a d'autres
qui ont aussi d'amande au delà de la
solidarité je pense par exemple à air
plus qu à approvisionner en masse par
nombre d'hôpitaux ou plaisir ou de
trappes
donc on a la chance d'avoir tiff
économie qui je l'espère pour l'instant
arrive à résister en tout cas pour les
grands groupes partout ils ont la force
de frappe n'est pas cette magie c'est
pour ça qu'il faut que nous soyons chat
aux côtés également une petite
entreprise est évidemment pas la même à
six fils à l'instinct
c'est le cas de m to m start up
spécialisée dans l'intégration des
technologies innovantes
ça a été très compliqué à partir de mi
février à mi mars
on a eu vraiment une chute des ventes
colossales
on s'est mobilisé on a décidé de mettre
en place des campagnes de promotion pour
soutenir va nous pour essayer de tirer
avec le bitoux si bas le manque à gagner
du bit ou bilan on a évidemment attiré
l'ensemble des mesures existantes de
chômage partiel mais qu'on a vraiment
diminué la voix de l'est qui lui permet
effectivement on a également repoussé
nos échéances de prêt de six mois donc
ce à un coût
hébergé au sein de promo paul la start
up a bénéficié de la suspension des
loyers non seulement 16 mai mais en fait
c'est indispensable
c'est indispensable parce que si on
était resté avec
les mêmes charges alors que notre
adversaire a chuté drastiquement
c'était juste pas possible là on aurait
été obligé de faire deux passes
solidarité du territoire durant la crise
mais aussi des autres entreprises
on a un groupe watson
depuis le début le ski club et on
échange régulièrement sur les les
mesures que les mécanismes que chacun
mette en acceptant notre en place donc
on essaie de faire tourner l'information
débrief les autres sur un rendez-vous
qui nous a apporté des nouvelles
informations
donc ça c'est plutôt c'est plutôt bien
et il ya une vraie solidarité également
c'est à dire que les uns et les autres
en culture de la trésorerie sont prêts à
prêter interentreprises
certaines entreprises sont très
sollicités du fait de leur activité
altruiste intervient au domicile des
personnes âgées
un quotidien difficile à gérer avec la
crise sanitaire
bien deux semaines on n'avait pas de
masque et donc on aller au contact des
personnes âgées dépendantes fragile avec
nos mains laver parce qu'on avait réussi
à se battre tout seul pour avoir du gel
hydroalcoolique
ensuite on a appliqué des règles
d'hygiène strictes et aujourd'hui on
arrive à avoir deux masques par jour
pour nos intervenants qu'ils ont droit
pour le matin avant de soi c'est pas
terrible mais je pense que c'est bien
bien l'utiliser en savoir bien les mains
avant de toucher
en essayant pas le réflexe de mettre les
mains dessus on a des surchaussures ont
mis environ une cinquantaine
enfin un peu moins 45 en temps normal
apple vend 20 parce qu'en fait on l'a 8
ou 9 de nos salariés qui sont en retrait
pour leur carte d'enfants il va pas
aller travailler ils ont leurs enfants
en bas âge 9 c'est énorme c'est un quart
de l'effectif
j y allais maladie habituel on aider
mais on est dans un secteur d'activité
on a régulièrement 15 % d'absentéisme
après il ya les gens fragiles
diabétiques voire plus grave certains on
a volontairement réduit notre activité
de presque la moitié ce qui nous a
permis de compenser la perte de la
moitié de nos salariés
le problème c'est que ça doure la
situation situation financière est
difficile mais il faut un acte nette
entre les mesures de chômage partiel et
plein de ges que chez l'état en
direction des personnes âgées
dépendantes et même de nous on n'est
vraiment pas à plaindre
[Musique]
durant cette crise sanitaire le
territoire s'organise transport collecte
des déchets qu'est-ce qui est maintenu
ou suspendus ont fait le point
[Musique]
au niveau des transports en commun
l'offre ferroviaire qui est opéré par la
sncf est toujours opérante un train sur
quatre
donc la ligne n principalement pour
concernant l'offre de bus actuellement
l'offre qui est opérée sur le territoire
de l'agglomération et l'offre de samedi
était donc c'est à dire qu'au second
tour on constate la première quinzaine
du mois d'août
ça c'est ce qu'on a durant toute la
semaine
néanmoins sur certaines destinations ou
certains points particuliers on a une
offre un peu renforcé notamment vers les
hôpitaux ainsi on prend les lignes qui
vont stationner des links décerné à
l'hôpital privé de trappes et on a une
ligne aussi qui dessert l'hôpital de
clamart qu'elle à 415 là on à l'offre
non pas du samedi est aimé de la semaine
est elle un peu plus renforcé et
amélioré et ponctuellement pour
certaines entreprises qui fonctionne
encore sur le territoire on a échangé
que ces entreprises et on a fait une
offre un petit peu ajustées ou un petit
peu sur mesure mais aussi vers certains
centres commerciaux et bureaux de poste
fermé un temps la vélostation est de
nouveau ouverte depuis le 27 avril
côté déchets les collectes reste
inchangée celle des encombrants sont
suspendus les déchetteries réouvriront
partiellement dès le 4 mai
côté loisirs parcs espaces verts et
médiathèques restent clos
les saint quentinois peuvent accéder au
contenu des médiathèques via le portail
i médiathèque
les écoles elles ont toutes bénéficié de
cours numériques via le plan seine
yvelines numériques
l'accueil des services publics est
fermée mais des échanges sont possibles
par téléphone par mail c'est le cas de
l'institut de promotion de la santé à
trappes
chaque fois que il y a des besoins
particuliers que ce soient des
professionnels de santé des
professionnels avec qui nous travaillons
mais aussi des saint quentinois
on a toujours un accès ali ps par le
biais de l'accueil téléphonique qui
fonctionne toujours beaucoup de
questions sur l'épidémie de kobe dans en
ce moment de manière globale par contre
au sein de l'eee ds on a maintenu
certaines consultations de partenaires
extérieurs comme le centre
d'addictologie de l'hôpital mignot on a
remis en place
le lieu écoute jeunes 1 pour tout ce qui
est toutes les questions liées aux
jeunes et à leurs familles et nous
gardons bien entendu encore plus durant
cette période un lien étroit avec les
professionnels de santé de tous ordres
les médecins généralistes le lien avec
les maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
mais aussi le lien avec les ehpad et je
crois que ça c'est c'est
particulièrement important en cette
période
le président m'a demandé d'assurer un
lien étroit avec l'ensemble des ehpad et
résidences pour personnes âgées du
territoire pour faire un point régulier
sur l'état sanitaire des résidents
aujourd'hui du ps joue un rôle
d'interface entre le monde économique
qui se mobilisent pour pouvoir fabriquer
notamment des visières parfois des blues
les sur blues et les besoins justement
que lee ps collecte auprès des
professionnels de santé pour ensuite
leur proposer des masques des rivières
[Musique]
où
aujourd'hui en tout cas les gestes sont
là l'état et là les soignants sont là
les français sont la loi mais là aussi
et ben moi je trouve que c'est un c'est
plutôt qu'est-ce qu'on peut ça se passe
plutôt bien
[Musique]
ce qui m'a aidé c'est fini encore une
fois à rester confinés au temps possible
et respecter les gestes barrières lavage
des mains masque distance à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]